un mandato en el que demócratas y
republicanos han podido trabajar en
conjunto Ese fue el primer mensaje del
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
en su discurso del estado de la unión un
llamado a la colaboración que vino
seguido por los temas económicos
el mandatario se mostró orgulloso por la
generación de empleos en el país 12
millones de trabajos y una tasa de
desempleo del
3,4%, el punto más bajo en años según
aseguróiten que también se refirió a una
de sus más arduas tareas contener la
inflación
estamos en una mejor posición que
cualquier otro país en la tierra tenemos
mucho más que hacer aquí en casa la
inflación está reduciéndose aquí en casa
los precios de la gasolina están
disminuyéndose un dólar y medio desde su
pico los precios alimenticios están
bajando no tan rápido pero están bajando
el mencionado techo de la deuda apareció
en la locución del presidente biden
reiteró su pedido al congreso Así que
hoy le estoy pidiendo al congreso que
siga esta esta idea complementamos para
que Estados Unidos y su congreso y Su
autoridad no sea cuestionada frente a
los padres
un joven afroamericano asesinado a manos
de las fuerzas de seguridad del país
biden se comprometió a impulsar una
reforma a la policía y luego hizo un
llamado contundente
devolverle el derecho al aborto al país
el congreso debe restaurar el derecho
que fue arrebatado en Rose versus
en la escena internacional biden elogió
la labor estadounidense frente a la
invasión de Rusia Ucrania y aseguró que
el apoyo no cesará
juntos
Hicimos lo que Estados Unidos siempre
hace su mejor momento liderar
unimos a la otan
creamos una coalición global defendimos
si nos mantuvimos firmes ante la
agresión de Putin de Ucrania a China
que Estados Unidos Busca competencia y
no conflicto y que el país tiene los
medios para asegurar su soberanía